we are so excited to talk with parenting
expert today caroline tobin who's gonna
tell us all things baby you know what
the holidays coming up i know a lot of
people that are expecting and a lot of
people that have babies and what's the
best thing to get them you have some
great ideas caroline
yes i do and i have a whole bunch of
products to share with you today
okay so i want to talk about this
product called the w4 elite this sounds
fancy what is it
it is fancy it is a quad stroller and
what's really nice about it is that it's
really easy to fold and unfold
to hold up to four passengers ages six
months and older and it's high face to
face seats with a foot well allowing
them to have better interactions it also
has a deep carriage with zippered mesh
panels for optimal ventilation and then
a zipper door for easy access and
storage what's really nice about this
stroller is that it's on the high end
it's built really nicely it's very
durable and it also has a removable
canopy for uv protection
this is a great product because as a mom
it's like everything all thrown into one
any parent can totally appreciate this
let's talk about the cuddle this just
warms my heart the name what is the
cuddle
yes so this is a baby carrier and it's a
really high-end luxurious baby carrier
it features four carry positions that
offer a growing child ergonomic
positioning to keep their spine and hip
development seat
healthy so it's much more than just a
carrier and it's comfortable and
customizable with breathable mesh fabric
and padded and shoulder waist straps so
you're really getting a high quality
carrier
now one thing when i my daughters were
babies that i loved so much was their
bassinet and this is the bassinet to end
all bassinets it's called the evie is
that correct
yes and you got that right it is a smart
bassinet
and you know how what makes it smart
what does it do
so it goes beyond your standard close to
the bed sleeper what this bassinet does
is it has
state-of-the-art technology built in to
help calm and get your baby back to
sleep and what's so cool about its
technology is that it has a unique
motion sensor a light and sound features
and it easily connects to any smart
technology like amazon alexa google home
or through its mobile app for hands-free
support and control
oh my gosh basta nuts have come such a
long way and if baby is sleeping that
means parents are sleeping and we love
that all around and that's a touch of an
app you can roll it which is amazing
all right let's talk about some of the
products you have behind you because one
thing with colds and flu season here
babies are gonna get sick and they're
gonna get congested and they can't blow
their nose on their own so you have the
solution for that
yes and i'm sure many moms have heard of
the nasal aspirators where you suck
through the tube through your mouth
what's really great about the nose bot
by dr knows best is that it is an
electric nasal aspirator it comes with
this little finger piece and it has it's
battery operated and it has three
hospital grade suctions so
rather than sucking through your mouth
you stick this in your baby's little
nose you operate the machine and it gets
all of that snot out and like the box
says
it's not a problem
and it's dishwasher safe too right yep
it's dishwasher safe and it's actually
hsa and fsa eligible which is really
cool because then parents can use health
care spending dollars to help
that is fantastic and once you got
babies nose ways totally clean you want
to swaddle them and i swaddle sets are
priceless tell us about this one
absolutely and these swaddles are just
luxurious these are my little unicorn
and their swaddles are made out of 100
cotton muslin so that means it gets
softer with every wash and it's just
super soft to the touch and little
unicorn is also known for their adorable
designs and they come in three packs and
this pack comes in llamas little check
marks and just a beautiful green color
so you can't go wrong with swaddles that
are soft and beautiful to look at oh
these babies are so aesthetically
pleasing in their little swaddle sets
and they they start at a reasonable
price too
they really do these three packs come at
40
so
not that bad for a very high-end
luxurious swaddle
absolutely the perfect gift for the
holiday season caroline you always have
the best stuff thank you so much for
helping us and for helping